Dark Souls 3 this is what it looked like
right from the bonfire yeah you could I
from the beginning proofs by Bandai
Namco in that text everyone gasped
everyone was excited yeah and got that
sort of a blood-borne dragging a body
around do you ever even drag bodies in
that game and he was dark souls 3 not
enough in terms of like exclusivity this
or that but this was our first look at
it Kevin you are something of a fan of
the Dark Souls serious thing what'd he
say about Dark Souls 3 i'm hyped but I
mean what is there to say right now we
have this little teaser trailer yeah and
not a whole and it giant Knight Rises
yeah but not a not a whole lot beyond
that I mean this looks very dark soul so
for me it's gonna be a question of
upsetting it's gonna be a question of
setting like what am I gonna be in this
sort of dark fantasy world there's you
see I mean there's a lot of similarities
between the first two dark souls all
this or it's got the usual like
callbacks you know it's got the crown a
kingdom that's no fallen and you know
there's going to be a kind of struggle
or you know it's always surrounding like
power struggles and what happened to
this kingdom where is the monarch that
kind of thing and obviously like some
sort of demon scourge or uprising
happening at the time so yeah it looks
it looks very similar to original
doctors we haven't seen a lot of the new
stuff obviously there was that leaked
earlier which suggested a lot of crazy
things like you know sacrifices and that
kind of stuff but we've got this huge
thing here and another thing to know
huge place another thing to note which
is really important in the leaked or the
rumors earlier there was talk of
Miyazaki being involved in this version
not confirmed in this at all that's Ram
he is currently believed to be working
on blood-borne DLC so we don't know
quite what he's doing now it may be that
he's actually left blood-borne and doing
something else we're not quite sure when
you first heard that rumor you were very
doubtful word yeah I was doubtful about
because he's the kind of guy I mean fans
of souls really dig into you know what
how Miyazaki is as a person and he's the
kind of guy that when he has a project
he really focuses in on that right I
mean he was known for being quite
involved in the dlc for original Dark
Souls
and and that kind of thing so it would
strike me as very unusual if he
abandoned dog shows to work on something
sorry blood-borne to work on something
else I reckon he would put a full stop
to blood-borne before he moved on but
having said that I mean the team from
software has grown significantly as you
can see they're working on two products
at the same time so it may be the case
that he's kind of delegated to his his
you know underlings all
second-in-command removing his
underlings he's loyal minion he wears
the crown so you know he's like make me
a game so it may be um he could come out
soon I think Sony would want to keep a
lid on whether he's involved right now
because a lot of blood bones you know is
being sold or people are reacting to the
fact that it's a Miyazaki game you know
there was a lot of backlash against dark
souls 2 even though there's a good game
like people were saying that we can tell
that he wasn't involved in this so for
him to bounce this early from
blood-borne would be a bit weird for a
lot of fans of the series but still it
looks good I'm enjoying I enjoyed what I
saw of it evoked the similar themes and
vibes from the original Dark Souls and
Dark Souls 2 so I'm excited I'm always
up for another Souls game oh yeah yeahs
Souls game dark souls 3 come down the
pipe at some time did they say early
2016 13 any of the trailer so look
forward to that next year